What is your opinion on Nietzsche's rejection
of Christianity?
That it glorifies suffering and victimhood,
how can it defend against a
conquering religion like Islam?
well, it has defended against Islam
in the past.
At the gates of Vienna,
it defended against Islam.
it seems to me that the
religion will be interpreted
in an adaptive way,
if you're under high levels of group selection.
the religion the society
has adopted will be interpreted in an adaptive
way, the adaptive bits will be drawn
out.
when it began, it was
an attempt perhaps you could argue like
multiculturalism or cosmopolitanism, it was
an attempt
for people who were in the middle of society
to gain status by virtue signaling.
It wasn't an attempt
to be a religion of an entire group.
it was an attempt for people within a
group to attain status, by
the way that the middle class always does,
by intellectual posing
and virtue signaling.
It did that, and became the religion
of the empire.
Fortunately
there was a large corpus of
texts involved, and it was open to all
kinds of interpretation.
And so it was
interpreted in a positive way.
Really the Jewish bits
were stressed.
We became the heirs of
Jewish ideas about
ethnocentrism, and being the chosen
people, and therefore
it became an adaptive thing.
now as we become maladaptive,
and the church becomes infested with
mutants, then you start to see
it becoming a force
of destruction.
I don't think
there's anything inherent in Christianity
that's maladaptive.
equally when Islam started
you can find bits in Islam which are
like that, and which are maladaptive,
which are the religion of the middle people,
that are
striving up and overthrowing
Mecca.
And then as
Muhammad builds up an empire, then the
nature of what Allah is telling him to say
starts to change, and it becomes more
adaptive as a group organization.
even within Hinduism
and other pagan religions you can find
these discourses.
so I don't think there's anything inherent
in Christianity
that's a problem.
it's inherent in the kind
of people that practice Christianity.
Those people are increasingly mutated
and increasingly kind of
multiculturalist and a mitre.
Yes, I'd agree.
I've
become very interested in Christianity of
late.
I don't see anything intrinsic
in Christianity that lends itself to these,
shall we say Episcopalian
interpretations, or corruptions
depending on your frame of reference.
the problem is not with the religion
it's with the people who are
contemporary practitioners of the religion,
who wish to use the religion as a
vehicle to promote their
moral and social agenda, which is
often deeply
at variance, with
the actual religious teachings
contained in the Bible.
Actually, a very good example of this is
the head of the Episcopal Church in America,
who's a woman.
she stood up, and argued
that Peter was having his privilege checked,
when he drove a demon out of a young lady,
who was enthralled to some demon
in in this biblical parable,
that he was actually jealous of her freedom,
and he realized the error of his ways.
If you read the actual parable it's
completely the opposite, it's nothing to do
with that.
it's about him
saving people from a very bad situation, which
had arisen involving
somebody being taken over by a demon.
it's very interesting
that a epistatic mutant like that
takes the side of the demon.
She was saying that Peter was wrong
to have carried out his duty to God,
which is what the Bible makes very clear he
was doing.
She's basically a witch.
The American Episcopal Church is run by a
woman,
who acts like she has a pact with Satan.
And thinks that women who have been possessed
by Satan i.e. women who are witches,
should be left alone, by godly people.
and those godly people only want to expel
Satan from them
because they're sexist.
There's a very special and warm place reserved
for that woman after death,
with the demons that she so adores.
In summary, given the church's embrace of
female preaching and homosexuality,
despite the strictest condemnations of it
in the bible,
you would be totally conceited to think
your ideal Pagan religion would not be just
as compromised and corrupted,
by chronic individual level selection, as
Christianity is today.